des aides spécifiques à la culture ont
été déployées après le premier
confinement afin de subvenir au manque d
entreprises et organismes culturels
le collectif 12 lieux de création
culturelle située à mantes la jolie a pu
toucher sa part on est en relation et
plusieurs services au sein de la drac
direction régionale des affaires
culturelles donc le service théâtre et
le service dans ce qui dans le cadre du
des fonds de la drac du plan de relance
nous ont déjà attribué un peu d'argent
quant au manque de services
chorégraphique
vingt mille euros ont été distribués au
collectif en mai 2021 pour l'aider dans
ses missions de création de spectacles
avec les artistes et d'organisation
d'ateliers de danse et de théâtre avec
les enfants notamment
c'est notre capacité à nous de
d'intervenir en coproduction un peu plus
avec les compagnies qu'on reçoit et qui
crée ici
nous on n'est pas un dieu très riche
donc elle a priori on a très peu
d'argent à m dans les projets eux-mêmes
là il se trouve qu'avec le plan de
relance on va soit directement quand
c'est nous qui payons les artistes soit
avec les compagnies qui sont là on va
forcément heureux et abondé sur les
budgets de création des aides qui reste
limité pour certains artistes dans une
période où le milieu culturel n'est pas
uniquement impacté par l'aspect
financier
en terme économique je pense que ça on
peut toujours faire mieux
cela dit je pense que la partie qui a
été le plus difficile à gérer c'est
vraiment le fait d'être toujours pris en
compte à la dernière minute par rapport
à tous les plans qui ont été faits et du
coup d'avoir toujours des informations
très tard qui nous a pas permis de
s'organiser comme on aurait préféré pour
la librairie du pavé du canal à montigny
le bretonneux les fonds du plan de
relance ont été perçus en octobre
dernier le plan relance ça a été une
participation du centre national du
livre à nos charges fixes durant le
premier confinement c'est un versement
qui est intervenue à l'automne 2020 et
ça prenait en charge nos loyers une
participation à nos loyers durant ce
premier compliment qui a été très dur
pour nous et où les commerces étaient
fermés la librairie comme le collectif
12 sont tous deux dans l'attenté d'une
nouvelle aide
la première pour permettre sa
modernisation le second pour pouvoir
assurer l'ouverture tout au long de
l'été